What's next for Rossy?
Well, we've got a fascinating interview technique
you may not have heard of.
MSN Money reports famous inventor Thomas Edison,
heard of him?
Well, he loved to start every interview
with something that surprised me.
He started interviews with soup, Drew.
Yeah, he conducted his interviews at lunch
and he ordered soups for everybody at the table.
And then he'd watch to see what you did.
And specifically, if you salted your soup
before or after you tasted it.
Because if the person salted it before tasting it,
they were out.
Edison didn't want people who acted on assumptions.
He wanted people who were thoughtful
and willing to investigate.
And I know as a cook, well, I cook every day,
and when I make something for someone
and they salt it or put hot sauce on it,
I'm like, how dare you?
Do you understand? I made this dish for you.
It's perfect in my eyes.
At least give me the respect of trying it
before you season it.
Can I get an amen?
Yeah, if I have to like, salt anything Pilar and I made,
I feel like I'm, you know, going to hell,
or as my daughter says, H E double hockey sticks.
Cute.
This story really does it for me.
And I'll tell you why.
Because the great minds of our world time history,
I am fascinated to know how did they become who they are.
So any little tidbit or morsel of information
into the mind of Thomas Edison,
hello, I mean this room could be pitch black
if he hadn't literally invented the light bulb.
Hey Thomas, thanks for great lighting.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
And what I loved about this
is when I was finding out about it, they teased me.
They said, okay, he made everybody eat soup
when he initially met them.
Why do you think?
And I was like, to see if they're a slurper?
I don't know.
I didn't know.
And learning that he wanted to find out
the trajectory of one's behavior
by, I don't even want to try this before I assume,
was deductive reasoning for him
to decide whether to join forces with that person or not.
Fascinating.
Are you going to try this?
Well, I do usually try it, 'cause I do,
I work with Pilar, we're cooking all the time
and I think it is really rude and embarrassing
to salt your food in front of people who made it.
Like, I have to really be desperate for it
because I know I'm saying directly to them,
Sorry, it wasn't seasoned perfectly.
What's weird is I have certain times of the year
where I can't handle salt
and I'm like, it's too salty
and there's like not salt in it.
So I don't know if that's a hormonal thing or not,
but I am sensitive about people who cook and salting.
You know what I'm sensitive about?
Don't order me soup. I want the salad.
How dare you?
What is the soup today?
Can we have that conversation first?
Well, finally we have a pick
from Drew's Little Yellow Book.
Yes, that's right.
It is my personal curation
that I work with everyone on the show with,
because I think that if I was a professional curator,
I would be happy.
So we refresh it every single week.
We're very thoughtful about it.
We do all the picks ourselves.
And this week I'm excited
because I did a social post about this,
and it just brings me to nostalgia city.
I'd just seen Spider-Man.
And has anyone seen Spider-Man here?
I hear it's so great.
It is so good and it is about the power of three,
which takes me back to the best time,
you know, a girl could ever have.
And that was being one of three with the "Charlie's Angels."
So Flower Beauty made
this Flower Beauty ex-"Charlie's Angels" pallet,
which is now available exclusively
with our beauty partners at CVS.
And you can get it on FlowerBeauty.com.
And it looks like a DVD
and there's all these treats with it.
And the colors are like angels eyes, starfish,
which is what Tom Green called me in the movie.
I liked it so much I married him.
Speaking of, there's the Chad, Dylan, good morning angels,
independent women.
Hey.
Because I will never forget being in the trailer
and we heard the demo from Destiny's Child come in.
I just heard that song the other day
and I was like, Drew, that's you.
You get a shout out on that song.
Lucy Liu with my girl Drew,
Cameron D and Destiny.
Charlie's angels. Come on.
And they were three women.
Yes, they were.
I mean, being in your early twenties
and trying to produce a "Charlie's Angels" movie
and hear Destiny's Child songs coming in,
it was the best time in the world.
That's so amazing.
Was it?
It really was.
It was, you know, we spent five years
making two of those movies.
They each took two years to make.
We trained, we toured the world,
we became best friends.
You know, it was us three girls.
And there is something about that trinity,
that trio, that triangle that's unshakeable.
And yeah, so this feels very meaningful
for me to be a part of and put out in the world right now.
So if you want to get in touch
with your inner little super hero,
go to CVS or the Flower Beauty website
and get your Flower Beauty ex-"Charlie's Angels" palette.
(upbeat music)